Okay, normally I would say Georgi Dinkov and Ray Peat, but we only have Ray today.
Georgi, hopefully he'll come and we'll work him into what's going on, but it's just going
to be a chat between Ray and I. How are you, Ray?
Very good.
Okay, so immediately before we talked about your newsletter, I wanted to get into, I felt
like I kind of approached the nutrition topic a little bit off center on the last episode.
I thought it was good, but I thought my questions to you were kind of holding you up like an
authority and it wasn't conscious. I wasn't trying to do it, but I was unimpressed with
my questions to you. So maybe, I don't know, is there anything you can think of that would
kind of broaden the scope of what we were talking about last time in terms of approaching
nutrition? And of course that will probably lead right into your new newsletter.
Well, nutrition is as complex and open and undefined as metaphysics or cosmology or anything.
It's a process of exploring and learning and figuring things out. And so it's never a closed
book, never a finished subject.
What is the problem with authoritarianism in nutrition? Like if somebody says, "Oh, Ray
Peat says to eat 100 grams of protein and 200 grams of carbohydrate," like what does
that negate from the individual trying to figure things out?
Everything is always changing and always individual and always changed by context. And so what's
true for one person today, where they are will necessarily be somewhat different when
they're in a different place doing different things. It's always looking at your problems
immediately in your context and to understand those, it helps to look at your history, how
you got to where you are and what you want to do to get beyond the present. So all the
dimensions have to be flexible. And so your digestive system reflects the things you've
done in the past. Your whole being is taking form, assimilating things you've experienced
and intend to experience. So you have to think of yourself as an intended participant in
everything, including your choices of foods.
Well, given how complex everything is and everything's a moving target, like how do
you even approach the subject?
With what you've been doing and how it has worked for you. If you've been living on sweet
potatoes and pork fat and you're doing okay in the middle age, then you don't see much
need for a change.
But what if somebody was grown up eating cereal and fruit snacks? What would...
They probably wouldn't have grown up very much.
Oh no, that's me.
So would the context change if somebody's writing you an email and saying, "Hey Ray,
I have a low pulse rate, a low temperature, high cholesterol, constipation." Is that what
makes the suggestions in context with what the person is explaining?
Yeah. All those things point to hypometabolism, low thyroid function.
And then, okay, so if you're saying something like protein, carbohydrate, calcium, et cetera,
you're giving those facts to that person and then it's up to them, like we talked about
last time, the creative act of conversation and then that person assimilating the info
and trying to extract something out of it that means something to them in their life.
Yeah, because their digestive system is going to have its unique oddities and it might turn
out that the high protein diet that would quickly cure someone if they already have
a sensitivity to serotonin and tryptophan, for example, they might have to work into
that very carefully with a diet emphasizing more gelatin than the highest quality proteins.
And then when somebody says, emails you and says, "I'm doing the Ray Peat diet," what
is your... what do you think of that?
First, I ask them what they're eating.
So you automatically assume that that was... so just to be completely honest here, so I
told you that I don't like that term, and I used to edit it out of podcasts, but it
has gained a lot of traction. But you think even using that term, I'm not saying you think
this, but it's probably kind of to really reduce your work into silly territory, saying
something like Ray Peat diet, you think?
Pretty much. From what I hear, people are eating on the Ray Peat diet. At least, it
usually excludes eating a lot of bread and green salads and beans. But those are, I think,
a few of the things that people generally realize can be harmful.
Maybe you could critique my approach, but I feel like when I chat with a lot of people,
there's always diet stuff, but it almost seems like if they're talking to me, it's past the
point of no return with dietary intervention. Is that a bad orientation to have? Because
usually they'll have labs as well, and I think the person will generally be kind of at the
end of the road. They'll have tried veganism or low carb or carnivore or et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera.
And I'm almost inclined to suggest the vitamin D to read hypothyroidism, the unsuspected
illness to get into thyroid and stuff. And of course, doing the dietary interventions.
But I don't know, could you say after 20 or 25 that a person is like, I'm sure you could
say earlier, but that it's very hard to get the metabolic rate going just with food alone?
Oh yeah. Almost everyone benefits from adding a little bit of thyroid. The human diet historically
probably always included some supplemental animal thyroid, whether it came from chicken,
stew, or fish soup, or sausages, or even blood. There was always some supplement coming from
their food. And since 1940, that has been legally banned from the American food supply
and pretty much other industrialized countries imitating the US requiring slaughterhouses
to take out the thyroid glands. And people generally just don't eat the blood. It's sort
of a taboo. While countries that save the blood and make tacos out of it or something
are getting a little bit of extra hormones of various types.
Something I've noticed, and I don't know if you feel the same, but there's something
about thyroid that a lot of people don't feel comfortable with. They'll take progesterone
or DHEA or pregnenolone, or they'll even be taking other supplements like ashwagandha
or rhodiola or just you name it. But thyroid is a lot of crossing the line to a lot of
people.
I think the drug companies and the doctors that have been educated under their influence
are responsible for that. The same thing that caused the agriculture department to order
slaughterhouses to remove it from the food supply. Broda Barnes tells some of the stories,
for example, in the 1930s, he observed that thyroid deficiency, among other things, caused
an extremely high rate of heart attacks and circulatory disease, infectious diseases,
circulatory diseases and cancer were the main killers in a hypothyroid population.
But when he started popularizing that, there was a reaction and JAMA published a story
about a doctor who had given a patient who had just suffered a massive heart attack a
supplement of, I think, two grains of Armour thyroid starting right off on a full standard
dose rather than working into it over a period of weeks and the patient died. And so that
created the propaganda that natural thyroid could kill you with a heart attack. And that
sort of thing was amplified when the Synthroid, I think, was the first one on the market with
a synthetic thyroxine product. I was in junior high around that time and there were several
fat kids and most of the kids already at that time were seeing doctors regularly and almost
simultaneously two or three of my fat friends said that they didn't have a hormone problem,
they were just gluttons. That had been taught to the doctors who taught it to their overweight
patients. And that went with doctors ordering their patients to stop taking thyroid. If
an old empirical doctor had recognized that people with chronic infections or obesity
or any of the 30 or so classical symptoms of hypothyroid, if people had been doing well
taking Armour thyroid, they went to the modern update, the well-trained doctors told them
to stop taking it because it was dangerous.
As I say, in obesity, is the part of the look of obesity just that accumulation of mucopolysaccharides?
Yeah, usually it is. It's a mixture of Cushing's symptoms, high stress hormones of various
sorts and they can go in the direction of high estrogen or high serotonin or high histamine,
high cortisol, high aldosterone, imbalance of the androgens, many different hormonal
directions just because your thyroid is not giving you the energy to contextualize your
physiology to round everything off.
I'm searching for it right now. I'm sure I will not be able to find it, but I feel like
one of the most important things you've ever said that really helped me clarify my extremely
blurry picture of physiology is you said when your thyroid is low, your pituitary doesn't
have much to do and your ovaries don't have much to do either and all the glands in your
body have an easy job when your thyroid is high.
I appreciated that so much because if you listen to other people in the health world,
it's so ridiculously complicated to figure out, "Okay, where does LH and growth hormone
and prolactin and FSH?" It's incomprehensible without a model that you've put together of
the energy stress. When the energy is low, the activation of the stress systems happens.
I think it's helpful to have in mind a mental image of a libertarian world or an anarchist
society in which everyone knows what to do and how to take care of themselves. That's
when energy is abundant and your thyroid is good. When the well-distributed energy availability
isn't there, then you have to look to be pushed to do what you're supposed to be doing. That's
where the thyroid, the pituitary comes in. The pituitary is roused in proportion to how
everything is failing. It pushes you this way and that way to make up for what you should
be doing just on the basis of your cellular needs and cellular knowledge.
Little W.D. Denkla, you weren't kidding. I feel like you've integrated his work so well.
All the papers were perfectly in sync with what you were saying. I was really shocked
when I got a hold of a couple of them.
Yeah, it's funny how he just disappeared from the world of knowledge.
He's sent to the backwoods maybe? What was it, Dave McCarron, the calcium hypertension
dude?
Yeah.
Let's take a small break here. Ray Peat is on the line with me. Georgi, I'm not sure
where he is. I hope he's okay. Ray, your newsletter is available by email, Ray Peat's newsletter.
Yeah, this issue isn't quite ready. I sent you a draft of it, but I'm still working on
it.
Awesome. People can subscribe to your newsletter by sending $28 to raypeats, with an S, newsletter
at gmail.com. Is that right?
Right.
Then they can send that same email address. They can send any of the titles of your books
for that. We'll talk about Progesthe a little bit later, I think. You know what? We never
talked about those videos surfacing on the back of a tiger. Did you think anything about
those videos being released on YouTube?
I haven't listened to the whole thing that you sent me. I've heard enough recording.
I thought they were good. A lot of people really were excited to see you in action.
I think that brings a different element to it. If that movie has done something good,
it's released those videos. Those were fun to listen to.
Then before we pass by this whole subject, I hope I'm not embarrassing you or anything,
but I think people shouldn't eat things that damage them and should eat things that taste
good and that provide the essential nutrients while making them feel good and function well.
Is that a diet? Is there anything left to speak about that in such an authoritarian
nutrition world? Even your stupid apprentice is misinterpreting things as well. Any room
to clarify?
I'm okay with that as a statement that what tastes good is very important. Your impulses,
your needs very often are responsible for what you're eating. But if you're supplied
with something not quite like what you need, then your taste might cause you to do something
like overeating on sugar or salt. Your cravings are biologically logical, but if the way you
are led to satisfy your cravings is abnormal, then your body might be tricked into malfunctioning
even though it's following its impulses. When your thyroid function is low, your blood
sugar becomes unstable, and so you tend to crave sweets and alternatively salt, which
helps you to use the glucose efficiently. But if you're mixed foods that would supply
those needs, if they're very distorted, then you might not correct the problem by following
your instincts. So you have to use your other perceptions and thought processes to figure
out just what it is your body is telling you to do.
What was that H.G. Wells quote? It's like, "Nature never appeals to intellect unless
intuition fails." Or what was it? Something else fails? Your instincts? Instincts fail.
Just before we get comments, I don't think I'm stupid. I'm just joking, everybody.
Okay. But one thing is, could somebody be in such a bad place that their orienting reflex
and intuition is just so jaded and blurry that, for lack of a better word, or suggesting
something to them is... Would that still be kind of a bad situation? How would you approach
something like that?
People tend to be immersed in the forces of their authoritarian surroundings. The culture
that they have integrated is telling them to do certain things, like go to the doctor
if you feel sick. If your body doesn't play a role in those cultural instructions, then
you'll go to the doctor, go to your job, maybe go to church, do whatever the culture prescribes,
and ignore what your body is telling you. But anyone can start to listen to themselves.
When they are mentally hearing instructions, a conscience telling them what they should
be doing, if they listen carefully, they'll be able to detect the source of where that
instruction is coming from. The guru, I don't know what he was officially called, but George
Gurdjieff, his basic principle was "Remember yourself." That really meant looking at what
your body impulses are doing and put that into conjunction with what your environment
is ordering you to do. Like you call up an image of who is speaking the instructions
to you, and then check how that image and set of instructions goes with your heart plexus
and your solar plexus, and check out what it does to your body. Usually you feel a shrinking,
compressed feeling in your body when you hear those conscience voices speaking to you.
I feel the opposite when I eat a churmoya. You said G.I. Gurdjieff, right? Is that the
guru?
Yeah.
He has a quote, "Without self-knowledge, without understanding the working and functions
of his machine, man cannot be free and he cannot govern himself, and he will always
remain a slave."
Yeah, that's pretty solid.
Okay, great stuff. I'm a little bit, is trepidatious the right word, to get into your
newsletter because it's such a dense newsletter. I'd love to be able to summarize it, but
I wouldn't do it justice. I guess, what was your motivation for writing it specifically?
It was sort of a shotgun approach to explaining a general approach. Like a mosaic, you put
down a lot of the material that is going to make up the image, and you hope that when
you get enough of the material together, you'll recognize what adds up, the general meaning.
So it's just a collection of these last 120 years, or 200 years actually, of observations
about how organisms work and how they might work. And then looking at the very clear experiments,
showing definitely that they don't work in certain ways and do work in other ways that
have been ignored, such as the purpose and intentionality of single-celled organisms
all the way down to bacteria, making decisions and planning and changing their behavior according
to what they perceive the environment to require. If bacteria can do it, why can't a human brain
cell do something at least partly as competent as that? I think the culture has created partly
to instill a helpless attitude in the public, has created this doctrine that our brain cells
are among the stupidest of all parts of creation. They can only signal by on and off information,
yes or no, nothing, approaching the infinite judgment ability that bacteria or planaria
or amoebas display.
Something that reminded me of something is like, everybody has their desired outcome
for society or how we should organize ourselves, but the gist I get from you is that that hasn't
even been an optimal way of doing that, hasn't even been approached, or maybe it has slightly
with Marxism or something, but like an environment that actually supported our physiology or
biology or whatever hasn't even been broached yet.
Yeah, that's someone like Kropotkin put together biology and culture and politics into a single
picture.
And there's something you mentioned in this article that I haven't thought about for a
long time is the primary, how do you say that, psyllium? And that's like a little, you call
it sensing organelle or something on the cell?
Yeah, like our retinal cells have this little finger tip, it's like a psyllium except it
doesn't wiggle. It internally resonates with what's impinging upon it, and that resonance
is made available to the connecting nervous system. Same with the ear or the olfactory
nerves or the touch movement detectors all through the body. Each brain cell even has
its own little antenna tuning it into the environmental conditions.
Okay, so we're going to pause really quickly. Ray, I'm actually going to hang up on you.
I'm going to call Georgi, then I'm going to call you back, and I'm going to pause the
screen everybody. And so you guys will be hearing music and we'll get Georgi on the
line. Is that okay, Ray?
Okay.
Okay, so I'll call you back in one or like two minutes or so. Okay.
Okay. Bye, Ray. Okay, hang on everybody. Okay, Georgi, we're live. Ray, we're live. Okay.
So there's Georgi. Everybody, this was probably my mistake. And so apologies to Georgi, I
think I told you the wrong time. Okay. So Georgi, we were going through, first we kind
of talked about nutrition. We got all that out of my system, which I need to talk about.
And then we're now we're going through Ray's newsletter. We just talked about the cilium,
the sensing organelle of the cell. And Ray, what are some of the other critical things
in this newsletter that you feel like are very important?
That's the theme that comes back over and over is the conscious purpose of each of the
component cells. Like the hologram idea is that conscious memories are not localized
in any part of the tissue, but people like Carl Preblum was the outstanding figure in
that line of thinking that the cortex through a network of synapses is able to make a hologram
that records awareness images in a non-localized hologram manner. And that is still limited
by the discrete nature of synaptic individual action, even though the pattern imposed on
that network of synaptic conditions or states, even though that's holographic, the underlying
substance of the brain function that Preblum advocated was still the old-fashioned behaviorist
mechanical on/off nerve cell is nothing but a switch-like conveyor of yes or no information
rather than something transmitting the complex image-like perceptions of each of the cells,
receptor cells or the nerve cells themselves containing a primary cilium in addition to
messages they're getting from other nerve cells. So it's trying to show that everything
that denies the complete participation of every cell in our conscious purposeful activity,
everything that denies that is based on an arbitrary assumption, which ultimately is
a false assumption that leads to behaviorism and mechanism and reductionism.
I have a question about holograms. Can a group of organisms, regardless of species, can sort
of band together and form a super hologram that combines their consciousness into sort
of like the collective consciousness that we all talk about?
Yeah, if they are sensitive and care to tune in to their surroundings, if they put their
primary cilium in contact with the draining cytoplasm, then they should be able to pick
up the whole worldview and metaphysics of whoever they're touching.
Do you think that may explain the ancestral memories and people having visions and contacts
with people that have been dead for a long time? Basically, they're like re-materializing
that portion of that collective consciousness.
Yeah, I think it's important not to rule out anything, not to assume limits to awareness
that aren't based on some kind of real evidence.
So maybe that could also explain Carl Jung's idea of the archetypes. These visions are
simply people connecting to the collective consciousness and extracting information from
it.
Yeah, and Michael Persinger's view that the resonant electromagnetic fields of the
earth and of our brain are coordinated, resonating with each other. And so brain-to-brain, by
way of the earth's resonant chamber.
Ray, you point out how things are fluid and changing all the time, but in the Cosmic Clocks
book, if he's right and the seasons are imbuing people with an essence or something,
isn't that something that's not really changing that much?
Oh, sure. Gravity and all of those things, the absolute meaning of a certain frequency
of vibratory energy, each thing has its intrinsic qualities. Every substance has its unique
identity. So the surroundings are part of your identity at any moment. The de-abstraction
of consciousness means that our being in its concreteness takes into account and assimilates
everything around us, including the state of the sun and the planets and the earth and
other people in that system.
So if two people are born in the same month, they might have a similar vibration, is that
right?
Yeah, they are more closely attuned to certain ideas and patterns. That's all it means,
but that's a lot.
You think that may explain part of astrology and the planets?
Yeah, that's what the Cosmic Clock, Gokulen, Michel Gokulen.
Where does that idea go off the rails, though? I'm so stupid. What's the thing that people
read? They're horoscopes. Is there some point at which it becomes total nonsense?
Yeah, but that's just a literary genre. It can be interesting, but it's just a person
creating a cultural artifact that to some extent recognizes that we are in the cosmos
together.
Well, here's a question. If you were going to spend your life with somebody, would the
month that they were born in matter to you?
I don't know. I think the clash of frequencies might make it more interesting than too much
harmony of frequencies.
There's an optimal antagonism, so to speak, contrarianism that a lifetime partner should
provide, otherwise it becomes boring if they're too harmonized.
That is sort of my impression, that you want to be able to go off independently and come
back and keep renewing others with your odd and idiosyncratic learnings.
The Chinese have a proverb that love is not so much gazing harmoniously into each other's
eyes, but it's about two people looking together in a similar direction.
I thought I had said that.
Okay, then it's a resonance, I guess, across time. Somebody may have plagiarized it off
of your website and then presented it as a Taoist saying from the 6th century or something.
Okay, well, how about we talk about Progesty and then we'll get into some questions because
we have some really excellent questions, I think.
I have one more question related to collective consciousness and Rupert Sheldrake. I don't
know if you saw, he did a famous experiment with another person who was a contrarianist
that it's impossible to have a collective learning experience and extracting collective
knowledge from the ether. And then they did this experiments, I think, with chicks, they
were training them. And then each successive generation of little chicks was able to learn
faster and faster a new task. So is there anything special that's required in order
to be able to tune in into that collective consciousness and knowledge, like a fast metabolism?
Are things that interfere with that process? In other words, making you more and more isolated
from the collective consciousness?
Yeah, I think everything metabolic and neurological affects it. Do you know who Andrea Puharich
was? Henry or Andrea was his first name, but Puharich wrote a couple of books exploring
what it is that opens the consciousness to remote viewing, for example. And he got the
Pentagon involved and interested in it. But he was seeing it in terms of a balance between
the parasympathetic and sympathetic system in a context that I think Michael Persinger
comes the closest to explaining how these nervous system balances could be operating.
He saw when people were asleep or extremely relaxed, he imagined that their nervous system
is able to sort of extend its feelers out without regard to distance, for example, tuning
into the Earth's resonance. But during anxiety, there's a contraction and everything tends
to fall towards the anxious center. And so if a person is in the sleep or relaxed parasympathetic
state, their feelers are out. And if someone related to them is in a crisis, anxiety state
of androdermic dominance, their relaxed feelers will be drawn to tune in and focus on that
center of crisis or anxiety or despair. And I think that might be where Michael Persinger
took up his basic orientation of Andrea Puharich was writing in the 50s and 60s.
I thought the Pentagon was also using LSD to drug some of the remote viewers and see
if that enhances the performance.
What do you think...
Mushrooms too.
How did you materialize from that research? How do you think it was applied? Do you know
anything about that?
There are several videos of some of the people who were involved working for the Pentagon-related
research centers, like the Stanford Research Institute. They have their personal experience
statements in videos that I think are worth watching.
Maybe they transitioned to Project Blue Beam for a fake alien invasion?
Say that again?
I said, maybe they transitioned to Project Blue Beam for a fake alien invasion?
Oh, oh.
I'm just joking.
Have you seen the news lately? They're always coming out of the Pentagon saying more and
more UFO sightings, something big is about to happen and everybody's glued to their TV,
which I guess is the goal, right? As long as they're not rioting.
I think it has served as a distraction for a long time.
Okay, well, let's get into these questions because they're... Oh, let's talk about progesterone
first. Ray, do you have any stories that you can grasp in your large bag of amazing stories
about progeste that we can talk about?
Oh, about any subject you want to apply it to. Dementia, epilepsy, sunburn, traumatic
injury, chronic conditions of all sorts, arthritis, asthma, pimples, acne, all kinds of stress.
Conditions on all the cellular levels, everything from personality problems all the way down
to whether a cell is inflamed.
This isn't directly related to progesterone, but a quote of yours that I sent to a lot
of people is, I forgot what newsletter it was, but you say something like, "Using progesterone
alone is not a good approach." You have to figure out what the problem is and usually
that's related to low thyroid function. So if a problem isn't miraculously solved by
progesterone, thyroid was probably the next thing to investigate.
Yeah. If you think you're dying of a migraine or a seizure, progesterone itself, a good
dose of that can very quickly bring you out of the problem, but then you have to figure
out what it was that put you into that unstable condition that needed progesterone.
And then last thing on this, some people are saying like, "If your nutrition is so good,
why do you need to add hormones?" And maybe a good response to that would be, "Our environment
is so terribly awful that maybe just even taking thyroid isn't enough kind of defense
from kind of the onslaught of metabolic problems we're faced with day to day."
Yeah. Even thyroid and milkshakes and quesadillas aren't always enough to make up for the horrors
that are imposed on us and some of the natural defects of the environment. Like we probably
should live more like naked mole rats sleeping in burrows in family clusters where we would
be producing a proper amount of carbon dioxide so that we would be soaked in carbon dioxide
for a good part of our lives, making up for the natural imbalance created by geological
changes.
I read a book recently about how people, the difference in sleep between these days and
back in the Middle Ages, and apparently people back then were sleeping in barnyards with
animals, 15 to 20 people all huddled together. And I guess the rate of degenerative disease,
maybe that's one reason why it was much lower. They were living like naked mole rats.
Yeah, having a cow and a pig in the house when you're asleep.
Makes life more fun.
You completely stole that out of my brain. I was going to make a joke about Ray, a long
time ago you said like an optimal society would include our animal friends and I was
going to make a joke about that and then you said it, Georgi, that's really wild.
That's how they used to live apparently. I mean, it was a book on anthropology. I don't
remember the author names right now, but he said that our current mode of life is drastically
different and judging from the archaeological findings and the examinations they did on
bones and whatever records, other records they could unearth, that he's saying that
apparently their lifestyle was conducive to much better health. They didn't have these
diseases back then.
Yeah, and I think carbon dioxide is always a basic factor of stress relief or stress
production depending on the concentration.
I have a question. Difference between thyroid and progesterone. Is there anything thyroid
does uniquely that progesterone either completely does not do or is much weaker or less capable
of achieving?
Yeah, the mitochondrial, you can uncouple the mitochondria by increasing your thyroid
temporarily to shift the ratio towards carbon dioxide from lactate and progesterone tends
to stabilize the mitochondria in an efficient, well-coupled condition. So like to get rid
of moles or skin cancers or such, a temporary, officially overdose of thyroid hormone. I've
seen fairly large uterine fibroids, for example, when someone was willing to stay slightly
hyperthyroid, keeping a resting pulse around 110 for three months, a large fibroid would
shrink permitting a pregnancy to proceed. And the same with getting rid of other types
of tumors and things that require corrective adjustments of the tissues.
So I thought that progesterone is thermogenic. Wouldn't that imply that it also uncouples
to a degree?
I think it achieves it by reducing loss as much as by maintaining, preventing the bypass
of the mitochondria. Keeps the mitochondria going efficiently, but at the same time, it's
reducing nitric oxide in the skin and preventing unwanted heat loss.
Okay, great stuff. Okay, so this is our first question. And the person quotes Heraclitus
and the quote is "Polymethy does not teach intelligence of things." And then their question
is "Much learning does not teach understanding. You can't really know something unless you
experience it. Are Ray's thoughts analogous to this?"
Yeah, you have to at least imagine experiencing it. The typical way of indoctrination and
school learning is by way of formulas rather than at least an imagined experience. And
literature and art should teach you, get your nervous system in the habit of thinking experientially
rather than in terms of algorithms and rote formulas.
Do you think the sterilization of learning, in other words, everybody's been turning
to not just a bookworm, but a very, what should I call it, rigid bookworm, may account for
the fragmentation of society? Basically, everybody's learned, but nobody really knows much about
the real world these days.
Yeah, true kind of learning always takes into account our world in common. And so that is
always an essential aspect of any little thing that you might know, how to play a music instrument
or how to make a fancy horse saddle or how to build a building. It always has to take
into account the overall world that we have in common.
So basically by preventing people from having common experiences, they essentially guarantee
that we can understand each other no matter how much we read about each other.
Yeah.
Great stuff. Okay, this one says, "Does Ray believe that some principles are worth dying
for?"
No.
I knew you were going to say that. Why?
Who wrote the principle? Whose principle is it? You have to look at the metaphysics behind
the principle. Make sure it isn't based on false assumptions and false metaphysics.
Would, so dying as an alternative to getting a vaccine is not rational?
Is there a connection?
Well, so say a hypothetical thing where it was like death or getting a vaccine. Despite
the horrors of getting a vaccine, killing yourself or something would not be a reasonable
option.
No.
Yeah.
It's better to be wounded and deformed by the vaccine than to be dead.
I was going to say war is, what is it? The expression is war is old man talking and young
man dying. So if somebody else wrote the principle, I'm with Ray on this one that you want to
be very careful whose principles you're trying to die for.
Right. So often there's an evil ulterior motive behind the principle.
Just to play devil's advocate, what about the phrase like, "Some things are worse than
death"? Like what if life was so much suffering after getting maimed by a vaccine?
I think your organism takes care of that. The stress hormones rise to the point that
it simply finishes off all of the processes.
I want to go on to this next question. What's like the, you know how W.D. Denkla was trying
to search for the death hormone. Do you feel like you figured out anything that he did
not figure out?
Oh yeah. There's no death hormone. It's just the death struggle of the organism against
these bad environmental problems.
And perceiving that there's no progress, right? Because if it's a great struggle but the organism
senses that there's progress, then this can actually, this shouldn't necessarily lead
to death.
No, no. Those processes are really last ditch survival attempts. The zooming up of your
growth hormone and prolactin and corticotropin, all of those are well-meaning survival attempts.
But they just accelerate all of the poor adaptations we're making to an inadequate environment.
Is death like, so those pituitary hormones are increasing, but maybe they cause prolonged
hypoxia and that leads to death? Is that right?
Well all of our adaptations are to a detective environment to one degree or another. If you
have to change your physiology to fit into the environment, the bigger those changes
are, the more your pituitary hormones are involved and the more it's diverting you from
what you would really like to be doing. And so the growth hormone has potential benefit,
but when you're forced to keep secreting it along with ACTH and serotonin and so on, the
outcome wasn't intended. But what it means is that you have adapted yourself, for example,
secreting more and harder insoluble collagen, turning yourself sort of into a tanned piece
of leather.
Saddle.
It makes you tough in a sense that can stand up to the environment a little longer, but
it isn't a good adaptive course to take. If we can improve the environment, have very
good nutrition, very good carbon dioxide rich atmosphere, a good amount of temperature and
sunlight and so on, then we can start mobilizing our intentional adaptive processes and in
that environment, the effort to adapt and become something else, you will tend to dissolve
the hardened collagen, remove the calcium from the soft tissues, put it back in your
bones and reconstruct a living vital organism. So the adaptive intention in a bad environment
leads you into degeneration. In a good environment, it leads you to restoration.
I was going to say, like three or four years ago, there was a doctor and he linked something
on Twitter and it was an article on fasting increasing growth hormone. And he tweeted,
"This is what Ray Peat does not understand." And he was inferring like the fasting was
increasing the growth hormone and you want to increase your growth hormone. And I just
had a little chuckle. Okay, next question.
The recent study on reversing the aging of the human immune system, they specifically
administered DHEA to block the aging, the pro-aging hormones of growth hormone. And
I strongly suspected the benefits that they saw from these treatments were actually due
to the DHEA, but it still pays off that they actually were aware that growth hormone has
strongly pro-aging effects. So you may want to send him this article or reply to his tweet
because it's pretty recent. It's from last year and it was in humans.
Great stuff. I will do. Okay, so let's get to this next one. What is it about Aristotle
that makes him a good scientist and what of his methods did the medieval scholastics fail
to adopt?
The idea of becoming, I think he took seriously Heraclitus' basic view of the world as everything
being in process. So I see Aristotle as a Heraclitian process philosopher, totally breaking
away from the platonic essentialism of an abstract finished universe. So he didn't have
a good data collection system, maybe the best in the world at the time, but it wasn't adequate
to create 20th century physics quite.
I remember an old interview, maybe it was John Berkhausen and he was like, "Ray, why
do you think William Blake was so smart and you said he didn't go to school?" Is there
a similar thing for Aristotle? Is there any way you can figure out how he knew so much
or his good orientation?
No.
Okay, fair enough. Okay, Georgi, interrupt me at any time. But okay, this is the next
one from Steve. He says, "How does the intangible of stress become a tangible phenomenon in
the cell? Where does it start?"
Reduction of energy, I think, is the general thing. Not getting enough energy to do what
it needs to adapt. And so it sends out signals that want more energy and that turns on emergency
organismic level processes like making more ACTH and cortisol to bring up the blood sugar
and get past the temporary crisis. But the cell ultimately needs to improve its use of
oxygen and glucose to properly restore the energy it needs.
Just a note, thanks for that, Ray. Just a note, all the super chats or super stickers
or whatever they're called will be donated to Ray. So just to let you guys know. Thank
you, Ray. Okay, this next one, we are going through these. Okay, it says, "How does Dr.
Peat organize his reading and research? Given he reads across various topics but is able
to put disparate yet related things together, does he have some sort of note-taking system
basically?"
Okay, you get the point. How do you organize your research, Ray?
I don't. My notes over the years are the most disorganized thing you can imagine. Occasionally,
they're helpful to remind me where I was, but definitely not like having a card file
of things that I've read, but just going from one thing that interests me to another.
Okay, just a minute. So this is shocking to me. So when somebody emails you about something
and then you reply to them and then you attach like eight abstracts, you're going to PubMed
and finding those abstracts or what?
Yeah, some of them I've put into my computer over the years for different reasons, but
usually I find things on PubMed that will answer a person's questions. Even though I
consider PubMed to be largely a propaganda source, it's a leaky propaganda source.
I want to second that, Ray's method over the years have struggled with many different methods
and eventually realized that the only thing that really worked was effectively acting
like a child, just following whatever interests you at the current moment in time. And at
least for me, synchronicity seems to play a big role. Things that I'm reading currently,
somehow miraculously in a few minutes later, I find other things that pop up that they're
disparate but similar, to use the quote from the person. Have you noticed the same thing,
Ray? That if you're reading on a certain topic, basically a similar concept will pop up in
another article, in another source of information, without you actually searching for it?
Yep. That contributes to my basic view of how the brain and the universe work. That
there's sort of a magic synchronicity, probably just because it seems like synchronicity or
magic just because we aren't clearly aware of the mechanisms that make it happen.
Have you noticed that children's play is structured very similarly? They basically base everything
quite naturally based on interest, right? They're not being told what to do when they're
little, and their attention shifts pretty quickly, but they always seem to be heavily
engaged into what they're doing, almost as if in a state of meditation.
Yeah. And with kids, their choices of foods tend to work the same way. They'll eat a lot
of something once and then maybe not touch it again for a month, but they're responding
to something in their physiology. And I think that is true in their play. There's something
in their physiology that wants to be developed as a true play.
So have you had similar experiences as an adult with food, which is related to the next
question that I think Danny is going to read? In other words, sometimes you eat a lot of
something and then the next week you encounter the same thing and you're like, "Eh, I
don't really feel like eating at all."
Yeah. I think it works the same in adults sometimes, but more often in children.
Georgi, can you push your microphone back a little bit? It's for some reason clipping
a little bit. Like, no, not close to you, farther away.
Oh, okay. Like this?
Yeah. Or if you move the actual unit a little bit back. Yeah. Okay, good. Thanks for that.
Okay. So speaking of that question, so this person made sure to clarify and they said
they weren't asking this so they could copy you. They were just curious. And so this person
says, "Can Ray go over what his past week of eating has looked like? Meal examples,
new preferences and tastes, or new experiments with food/meal ideas?"
They tend to cycle. Today, so far, I've had an omelet, milk, orange juice, and coffee,
and then some leftover mushroom soup and carrot salad and orange juice and coffee for the
afternoon. Yesterday, I had an appetite for a cheese taco, a toasted taco with melted
cheese on it. And it just is what I feel I have an appetite for that particular day.
I think our last chat with you increased tortilla sales by like 1,000% all over the world.
Ray, you're responsible for the inflation of food we're seeing all over the US.
I noticed that many years ago when I discovered that the Safeway store was selling chicken
necks at something like a dollar a pound. And I found two or three thyroid glands in
every package, a couple of pounds of necks. I mentioned that in my nutrition classes and
never saw a package of necks again. They constantly were buying them up and then Safeway stopped
selling them, I guess, when the word got out that they contained thyroid glands.
You've got to be careful about those liver sources and other things that you need to
feel well. Yeah, for sure. Okay, next question here. And then I was interested in, after
these questions, asking you some things just about, of course, the culture stuff that we
always go over, but I thought this would be a nice break from just getting questions from
Georgi and I. Okay, where ... Now I've lost my place in these questions. Thanks everybody
for watching. Give this episode a like. Again, all super chats or super stickers or whatever
are donated to Ray. And sincere appreciation for Ray and Georgi being here and taking
their time to do this for everybody. Okay, building off of the idea that when thyroid
is functioning properly, you can think any way you want to about anything. Can you explain
more about the physiological aspects of how our energetic state influences our thoughts
and perception? Is there an energetic component to thoughts that matches biological energy,
or is it more so that a higher energetic state ... And I think I clipped this question, but
you get the idea. Yeah, I think the high energy state is a
relaxed state of readiness. The infant brain with a very high metabolic rate easily goes
into complete relaxed sleep and replenishes its energy so it's ready for another episode
of very intense activity. That kind of episodic energy burst, I think, tend to give you an
image-oriented kind of chunky approach to reality and the problems you're thinking of
rather than just doggedly assembling bits and constructing a knowledge system out of
learned bits. It gives you an animal quality to your episodes of learning and thinking.
And like ruminating on the past, so that's that junky quality you're talking about, like
thinking about things that have literally no importance and can't move you forward?
Well, sometimes it's necessary to think about where you've been to better understand why
you want to go in a certain direction. So ruminating can be constructive.
One last thing. So I think you specifically talking about that quote, somebody emailed
you about trauma a long time ago, and you basically said if the toxicants and the energy
substances and things are right, you can kind of think how you want to about past events.
And so that just includes kind of intermittently thinking about things that have happened in
the past. That doesn't mean you reject what's happened to you. You're just not stuck on
them. Is that right?
Yeah. My view of memory is that it's a developmental state. Even though it passes in a flash, still
it changes our development all through the organism. Every little so-called memory, memorable
experience that we have is changing the structure of our organism. And it's simply scanning
the state of our organism when you're ruminating or considering the meaning of the past. It's
all present in the state of your organism. When you're remembering, you're really being
present to yourself.
Interesting. Okay. This one is, "May you ask Ray what he thinks about some people being
more subservient to authority than others? Why do some have this innate rebellious attitude
while others follow the narrative, no questions asked?"
It has a lot to do with your metabolic energy, how much DHEA and progesterone and pregnenolone
are circulating through your system. So you feel resilient enough to reject every little
thing that seems unhealthy.
Great stuff. I didn't know if this was true, but this next one says, "Thoughts on Chernobyl
steadily reactivating." Is that right?
Say it again.
It says, "Thoughts on Chernobyl steadily reactivating." Is that a thing?
I'm not sure what it means. The area around Chernobyl continues to be extremely contaminated
and deadly.
There were a few articles, I think it was last week, at least the ones that I saw, that
said that the detectors that are there in the sealed reactor that is under a concrete
sarcophagus, they're detecting levels of radiation that are increasing and can only be produced
if the chain reaction is somehow intensifying.
That's definitely possible. Molten fuel, for example, is moving around.
Yeah, they were thinking of essentially sending a robot in there and basically sealing the
actual reactor, the smaller portion of it, with graphite, is what they said, to sort
of stop the chain. They will try to stop the chain reaction, but they're also kind of hedging
their bets and saying, "It may actually trigger a nuclear blast, so we're not promising any
results."
We'll do a few more of these and then we'll let you go at, well, it's my time, your 6.30
time for sure, Ray, so we won't keep you too long.
Okay, "How to stop, slow down body hair and beard hair growth. Could topical progesterone
work or something else?"
There were studies published in France in the 1960s of topical progesterone showed women
with definite sideburns and whiskers and masculine chest hair who, through topical progesterone,
two or three months later, showed them with a feminine, hairless face and chest.
And same thing for a man, right? That would be the estrogen maybe activating the adrenals
and causing the skin to kind of be androgenized, is that right?
Yes, when you're deficient in those protective hormones, especially pregnenolone and progesterone,
then you're likely to overdrive the stress hormones and come out with too much androgens,
especially in women, and too much estrogen in men.
And just an update, on the Coke here, now all of the bottles say "Reducido Azcar,"
and then I talked to the dude that works at the Tienda and he said all of the Coke now
is like that in Mexico. And so that is a thing now, like they've just changed the formula
of Coke and all of it tastes different now. And the dude confirmed that, just to give
an update for anybody who cares. So that is very sad day.
What kind of sugar is this?
I wish I had written it down, but it was like a mixture of new types of sugar. This is totally
new to you, right?
Yeah, I hadn't heard it at all.
I told the guy it was "Muy Malo," and he laughed. Okay, so let's get to these last, I skipped
over a few, but let's get to, okay, this was a popular one. Is there a way to remineralize
teeth and heal cavities?
Basically no. If the enamel is just slightly eroded and the protein framework is still
there, yeah, it can be very nicely remineralized. But once the decay has gone through the thin
layer of dentine and has broken down the dentine, gone through the thin layer of enamel and
entered the dentine, then the tooth from the inside can close off the progress. If you
have a very stable hormonal vitamin D calcium balance, the tooth from the inside is constantly
renewing the cytoplasm in the dentine channels and will close off, create resistance to the
advancing cavity. But I've never heard of being able to fill a cavity from the inside.
It can simply stop the progress.
Have you seen that study that got published in 2018? I think it was basically they showed
that applying aspirin topically to the tooth, despite being acidic, actually led to tooth
regeneration. I forget how much was regenerated, but it reversed that process and some actual
regeneration happened.
Was it in the dentine or just the enamel surface?
That I don't know. I mean, it may have been just a very, very shallow cavity and that's
why it regenerated. But I remember it was aspirin, it was topical solution. And they
were surprised too. They thought that because it's acidic, it should actually erode the
tooth even more. But in fact, it actually led to some regeneration.
I think the acid theory of tooth decay has tremendous weakness. The idea that bacteria
just make an acid. I think it's much more complicated than that involving antibodies
and subtler handling of the minerals.
You may have seen it. There was a study earlier than that back in 2015, which said that unbeknownst
to most people, competitive athletes have extremely poor dental health. And that study
tied that poor dental health to low thyroid function because of the constant exertion
they were having.
I didn't see that one, but thyroid is the main regulator of the health of your saliva
and the quality of your saliva really is in charge of what happens to your teeth on the
outside and it tends to correspond to the vitality of the pulp chamber, which maintains
the dentine from the inside. But definitely the thyroid is the main hormone governing
the quality of saliva.
Great stuff. So I was thinking for the last 25 minutes, we would just tune into the Great
Reset and is there anything new that, of course there is, but is there anything to focus on
that's happening that's mildly interesting or reveals something that they're doing?
The established lies are coming apart and resistance is starting to show some effects.
Do you mean the Wuhan lab stuff?
Yeah. Ron Unz, he has a good article showing the value of two articles, different theories,
whether it was a lab accident or not, but then he gives a third interpretation that
everyone seems to be carefully avoiding, which is the long established germ warfare policies
of the United States. Unz goes through the facts that align so much more perfectly with
this third option than with just the lab accident or not theories.
There's another article on the site, a recent one on his site, which says that basically
it was a failed bioweapon attack on China launched by the United States and when the
Chinese didn't take the bait, then basically the US said, well, we have an opportunity
to use it on somebody else. Who would that be? Well, our population and the rest of the
world and we're going to use this to tighten control for whatever other reason we have.
Iran really was the second target, just the elite politicians in Iran had a very terrible
attack right after China. I think one misapprehension of the germ warfare people, they really seem
to have believed that the ACE2 enzyme, they thought it was the receptor that let the virus
attack and enter cells. I think they really believed that. And the fact that the Chinese
have about 30% higher expression of the ACE2 enzyme, especially in women, women have a
higher expression than in men and in both sexes, the expression of ACE2 decreases with
aging. But I think the fact that the Chinese have such a thick expression of this ACE2
anti-angiotensin enzyme, I think that led people to believe that the Chinese would suffer
much more intensely from this virus than Americans or other racial groups. But in fact, the ACE2
is what defends us against inflammatory attacks such as virus. And so the populations that
express the most ACE2 rather than being the most susceptible to catching the virus, they're
the ones with the most powerful means for resisting the inflammatory consequences. So
women, young women are the most resistant, but it happens that the Chinese heredity gives
them an especially high resistance.
I'm not saying it wasn't produced in a lab, but isn't the idea that it's a bioweapon kind
of conflict with the idea that it's not harmful at all? I mean, the activation of the renin
angiotensin system, but that all of this stuff is just way overboard and just about control.
Yeah. Rona Unz talks about that, that it wasn't intended to kill many people and didn't really
kill lots of people, but it was a nuisance just like an effective cold virus. But the
theory was that it would give Chinese 30% more colds than it would give Americans.
Oh, interesting. And for this whole thing to work, would they really had to have created
something? I don't buy into it, but the alt narrative that there's nothing, you know what
I mean? And actually a lot of major, I think Patrick Timpani, he keeps listing people saying
that there is no virus, but isn't the whole thing now that, what's that word they say
for making viruses? It's in the news all the time now. You know what I'm talking about?
The Fauci keeps saying it, like they'll enhance a virus or whatever.
Oh, gain of function.
Yeah, gain of function. But anyways, you're saying they had to have created something,
right?
Yeah. Luc Montagnier has clearly expressed that he, in his lab work, understands how
you create a gain of function. You find some species difference, like the human expression
of the ACE2 enzyme was chosen as a target. And so they just adjusted the enzyme to be
able to stick more firmly, adjusted the virus so that it would stick more firmly to that
enzyme. And the people are arguing against the whole existence of viruses are in a way
onto something because the mechanism by which we maintain our genetic and physiological
interactions among the various parts of our body, the circulatory systems are carrying
exosomes in which our cells put out genetic messages that are sent to other cells. But
this apparatus is the same one that the viruses use to replicate the viral message. And in
size and structure, our exosomes are in most ways indistinguishable from the things that
are classified as viruses. And so if you give a vaccine or catch a virus and get the nucleic
acids into some of your cells, those cells experiencing distress will increase their
production of exosomes, which pick up relevant bits of nucleic acid and proteins and lipids
and package them in a little virus-like package, which those exosomes then travel to different
parts of the body and are excreted in sweat, in the breath, in the urine and so on. And
so we are creating things that function like viruses and look like viruses and are made
in the same system in the cell that replicate viruses. So I think the people that deny that
there is such a thing as a virus are really just helping to call attention to the probable
origin of all viruses was the mixture of external transmitted nucleic acids, basically transmitted,
excreted and transmitted in the form of exosomes as a natural physiological adaptive process.
Now, aren't the mRNA vaccines essentially an artificial replication of that whole exosome
paradigm, but in a really harmful manner?
Yeah, I don't know how aware the virus people were of exosomes, but that's something that
is completely left out of most of the discussion. In fact, the vaccine nucleic acid, the messenger
RNA can be packaged into exosomes and transmitted to other cells, including our germ cells and
into our sweat and transmitted to people we touch or breathe on.
Speaking of that-
A couple more things on Montagnier. He said as early as March, 2020, that the virus is
most certainly man-made after having studied it for a couple of months. And he basically
said this virus contains sequences that are not known to occur in any natural virus of
the same category of the coronavirus, including a protein sequence that is known to be part
of the HIV virus. And then of course, immediately French press started publishing articles saying
he must have run out of his anti-psychotic medication.
Yeah, what they're doing now, the last two or three days, I think they've created another
crazy story claiming that he says all the vaccinated people will be dead within two
years just to make him sound crazy. He didn't say that, but by inserting that claiming that
he said that they're denaturing, defanging his actual message that the virus was deliberate
and stupid and dangerous.
What about his other message from the same interview, which he said that having a vaccination
campaign during pandemic is absolutely the dumbest thing a public health agency can do
because it's actually causing the virus to mutate in order to avoid the vaccine and evolve.
And that's what's creating the new "variants". And in fact, it's making people more susceptible
to dying from these new variants due to the antibody dependent enhancement process.
Yeah, that's the sort of thing he says that they want to shut up by making him sound crazy.
Do you think there's any truth to that? Basically, that these people are now more susceptible
to dying from future encountering either another coronavirus or any virus really? Because you
said something similar about the flu vaccines, that some of the deaths from coronavirus were
following flu vaccination campaigns.
Yeah, but several studies have shown that people who were vaccinated for influenza the
following season were much, much more likely to catch a coronavirus. So you become partially
immune to influenza, but instead you substitute increased susceptibility to coronavirus infection.
So the whole thing, all of the facts invalidate the claims both about influenza vaccines and
the COVID.
So which one do you think is a bigger worry for a vaccinated person? The chronic inflammatory
state, which these vaccines will probably trigger and keep for a long time, potentially
for life and even transgenerational, or the potential for ADE when this person encounters
another virus later on in their life?
The risk of exaggerated antibody intensification of symptoms, the risk is so great that even
though we don't know how often it's going to happen, it's just a very crazy risk to
take for the world population.
So these people could die 10 years from now when they encounter a completely different
virus and of course you'll never be tied back to the vaccine they got 10 years ago.
Yeah.
I wanted to get your thoughts on the Israel-Palestine stuff, but one question I have for you about
that is why, and maybe this is wrong, but why doesn't Israel give the Palestinians vaccines?
Or is it some kind of reverse psychology thing that they're withholding vaccines from?
Part of the truth is probably that like American, black people often look at the history of
what the CDC has done experimenting on black people, experimenting in other countries,
doing experiments in the guise of vaccine where really they're doing something else.
I think a lot of Palestinians are likewise fearful of being experimented on by the vaccinators.
So that would just be a no-sell immediately, like if Israel was like, "We have vaccines
for Palestinians," they would never accept those?
If I was a Palestinian, I don't think I would.
No, I mean, there's actually documented cases around the world.
I think in Afghanistan and Pakistan, they kicked out representatives of a World Health
Organization because now they're firmly convinced that the vaccines that they're getting, donations
from Western countries are intended to sterilize the population.
And we have now some evidence that the same thing is happening in Africa.
So I don't think it's just the Palestinians that are mistrustful.
It's kind of like a third world being always suspicious of the rich people and their attempts
to provide benefit to the poor plebs.
They will never take that openly.
Right.
I kind of understand why the elites here would want to depopulate the US, but why would they
want to do that in Israel?
Oh, well, they're set on getting rid of the Palestinians.
But why would Israel vaccinate its own citizens if the higher-ups, assuming that they understand
that this vaccine is to harm people?
I'm not sure what they understand.
So Netanyahu doesn't think it's possible that he doesn't know it's for depopulation?
I think that's possible.
In other words, the elite may be sometimes stupid and not know that what they have unleashed
on themselves.
Is that what I'm hearing?
Yeah, the elite isn't unified.
On a world scale, they're unified in the sense of being a ruling class with its own interest.
But within that power system, there are constant subdivisions of power conflicts.
And so you have to look at each country's power elite and how it relates to the others.
So like Maxwell doesn't care about some Israeli citizen that, I don't know, shine shoes or
something, just as much as a Rockefeller doesn't care about an American.
Kind of the same type of thing?
Yeah.
The European Jews have a very race-like discrimination against the Jews of other origins, especially
African-originating Jews.
Interesting.
Okay, so we have about eight minutes left.
Is there anything that we should navigate to quickly before calling it a day?
You know what, though?
Let me answer that question that I just said.
What do you think about the ousting or throwing under the bus Bill Gates?
I haven't heard much about what's going on.
Well, he was framed as a womanizer and then Melinda and him got a divorce and now his
name is like the media is all over him as a bad person.
It has been coming out gradually ever since Epstein killed himself, supposedly.
The story was involving Bill Clinton and lots of the elite out political crowd and he was
in it right from an early stage.
It just takes time to develop.
I know that, but do you think he was impeding kind of their goals?
Like he has such a bad reputation now that they're like, "We need to do something
to get this guy off the air," or something like that?
I know I'm asking you to speculate, but it just seems so odd that they turn on...
Like that Epstein stuff has been around for a very long time and then the media just automatically
picks up on it now.
Like, it doesn't make any sense.
I think the media are in turmoil.
They are confused by things leaking out that shouldn't have, and I think they are in the
process of reorganizing and trying to find a new equilibrium that can be sustained, but
everything does seem to be falling apart.
Yeah, I saw an article.
It was in Russia Today, which not many people read, but basically they're saying that Western
media is largely collapsing due to...
Also I mean, no pun intended, collapsing viewings and readings from the general population.
Nobody seems to be going to mainstream media anymore.
I mean, an increasingly smaller percentage of people are reading it, which means less
ad revenue, and unless the government starts to pay the media directly to subsidize them,
they don't really have a survival plan.
Yeah, I think those forces are really stirring up confusion in the mass media on different
sides.
Okay, absolute last thing, and then I'll read the super chats.
Ray, I feel like the olive oil on the carrot or mushrooms is like a revelation.
I think it works so much better than coconut oil, and so I just want to...
I think my digestion is the best it's ever been, and the only thing that I can think
of that I changed was the olive oil.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, I noticed the same thing.
There are allergenic properties in coconut that even extreme refining can miss, but olive
oil in the unrefined state, it's a fruit oil, not a seed oil.
And as such, it brings with the oil a lot of anti-inflammatory, very protective intestinal
redesigning and protecting drug effects.
One last food question for me, because since you brought up the food thing.
Ray, I noticed you've commented in the past on orange peel as being very high in things
like naringenin, hisperidin, et cetera, et cetera.
What are your thoughts on orange peel wax, which is available as basically food grade
material and it's got this really dark red, almost brownish color, which makes me think
it's very, very high.
It's a concentrated form, basically, dietary form of all of these flavonoids.
What was it called?
Orange peel wax.
It consists of about 50 to 60% of polycorsonil basically, but its color is very dark red,
almost like a brick, which makes me think it's high in these flavonoids that we know
have protective effects.
It sounds good.
I'll find out more about it.
But meanwhile, marmalade tastes very good and has those same things.
So does the pulp need to be removed?
It's only basically a thin scraping of the peel?
Is that what's the beneficial part?
Pretty much the whole thing, the white stuff as well as the orange stuff, has those flavonoids.
Okay.
So here are the donations.
My computer doesn't start.
Okay.
Peggy for $10.
Jean Pack for $20.
Thank you so much, Jean.
Plu Plus for 50 SAR.
I don't know what that is.
David Hendricks for $20.
Thank you so much.
Janet Pack for $20.
Thank you so much, Janet.
Piordor, I won't even try your last name, 199.
Thank you so much, Piordor.
Linda Belfry for $5.
Thank you so much.
And Pure Therapy for 499.
Thank you so much, Pure Therapy.
And then there's one last one, I think from Michelle for $50.
Wow.
Okay.
I will send all of those to Ray.
Let me do one more advertisement for Ray here.
The newsletter is available by email now.
It's $28.
You can send it to raypeatsnewsletter@gmail.com.
And then you can purchase progesterone, Progeste from Keenogen by emailing Catherine at keenogen@gmail.com.
And each bottle contains 3,400 milligrams of progesterone.
Okay.
That is the last thing.
Ray, any parting words?
And Georgi, any parting words?
Not really.
I mean, I'm glad that the narrative is falling apart and hopefully the elite will consume
itself and not force us to take matters into our own hands.
Well, okay.
Ray, stay on the line.
We'll just keep you for one minute extra.
Guys, thank you so much.
Give this episode a like, share it online, et cetera.
We have an amazing listenership.
Sincerely appreciate it.
These are always extremely fun to do.
Sincere thanks to Ray, sincere thanks to Georgi for making these possible and our amazing
audience for also making it possible.
Thanks everybody.
Take care.